once more into the minefield so I know
when I started doing lgbtq+
representation in media topics that I
was gonna try and limit it to once a
month but I also didn't make the
allowance for his stuff comes up I might
have to talk about it more and there's
been further wrinkles both in the terms
of Scarlett Johansson being cast in the
project which I talked about last time
she was originally cast to play a trans
man on the backlash about that I gave my
feelings about that and I kind of want
to follow up in it not just because of
what happened since then but because of
some things that kept coming up in the
comments of that video so since we're
doing at this particular topic that does
mean we are going to swap out that I'm
gonna get a little more relaxed with the
look so to update you in case you
weren't following Scarlett Johansson has
dropped out of the project to reiterate
quickly the project was called
rub-and-tug it was about real-life trans
man
Dante Tex Gill who was around in the 70s
into the early 80s running a chain of
massage parlors that were actually
houses of ill repute he was running
prostitution and and was bumping up
against the local organized crime by
doing so it's an interesting story is
one worth telling
now since her departure which was very
clearly done in the wake of the
controversy and she put out a well
worded statement I can't personally help
but still feel a bit cynical about it
and that it's just a very well worded PR
band-aid but it was well worded and it
seemed well considered so while I still
have issue with everything that happened
the word she chose as she exited were
well chosen that being said the director
Rupert Sanders stayed on the
jacked and is officially still on it but
basically the finance ears are not
particularly interested right now and I
was shopping for a studio again or at
least they were last time I checked
which gives away the game that the the
people the studio prepared to back it
were backing Scarlett's name and had
little to no interest in the project
otherwise now some folks really took
that as a validation that the only way
that these stories can get told is to
cast a big-name actor and obviously
there's no trans man actors I don't want
to get too much into that into that
element again but I'll reiterate what I
said before there are other key roles
that she could have played and there are
many indie films historically over the
years that had been financed by getting
a really big name for a supporting role
I mean that's how that's how Good Will
Hunting got financed Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck were nobody but they managed to
land Robin Williams in a key supporting
role and you could have easily put
Scarlett Johansson you know as the key
supporting role to get the financial
backing to get neo to put upfront in the
marketing so that you could get the
financers she could have been Dante
Gil's girlfriend longtime girlfriend
which he did have could have been any
number of other people and the film
still could have gotten could have
gotten done so I will continue to make
the argument wasn't necessary to cast
her in that role in order to still
attach her to the project and get it
made but the thing is ultimately she did
she doesn't appear to have gotten
attached to this project because she
felt the story to be told she got
attached to the project because she
wanted to play that role specifically
and again to be fair this was the words
of her rap not her own exact ones but
she didn't really redact those but her
representatives response at the initial
pushback being as dismissive as it was
and citing a whole bunch of cisgender
actors who have won awards playing
transgender kind of really tough and for
why she had an interest in that part but
so that's the context in which I'm
talking about this again but I kind of
want to springboard off that
to talk about the bigger question that
has come up I think in the wake of this
and it's a question that does deserve
discussion because while it is while it
feels clear for me I think for a fair
number of people on on both sides of the
the argument that I'm about to talk
about there is a fair amount of nuance
and that's the thing when you try and
break it down to a simple bullet point
it it just becomes a mess but that's
what people always try to do the the
Internet and the headlines and Twitter
even at 280 characters now doesn't have
the space for nuance but I'm gonna try
anyways so should only trans people be
playing trans actors that is the
question it's a question that has been
brought up both as a logic trap which
I'll get to the second half of that when
it's being used that way or is a
legitimate question you know from people
trying to better understand the the
issues and the conflicts and the
concerns that people have about these
sorts of parts so the argument basically
goes something along the lines of look
it's a part they are an actor and they
are being called upon to play a part and
they're gonna be they're always gonna be
different from what the part is they're
called to play actors fake accents all
the time you know actors acting your
play roles that are slightly older
slightly younger than they themselves in
fact are the people you know they're all
there's a whole range of things that
actors for lack of a better term fake
why is playing a transgender character
different from that that that is an
argument that is that makes sense on its
face the issue is is there are trans
actors who are getting little-to-no work
because they are trans actors and
because they are limited
pretty much exclusively to playing trans
parts and very few parts are written
explicitly to be played by trans actors
which means that there's a very small
pool of roles that are viable for a
trans actor to ever get to play so it's
a little bit galling when a sis actor
swoops in and takes one of the few
leading roles potentially away from
trans actors who are really trying to
cut it in this business and again
especially when you're doing something
that's a true story to bring it back to
the Scarlett Johansson thing if you're
trying if you're trying to make a claim
of this is a story that should be told
this is a community who has a story that
should be told to sort of cut that shut
that community out of the telling of
that story is a bit conflicting let's go
with that we'll be polite and go with
that and sort of the other thing about
that is every now and then you will get
you know trans people playing trans
parts but by and large especially lately
if it's a lead part it's play biases
actor so I mean even if you take sort of
the big break out trans actor of the
moment which is Laverne Cox from orange
is the new black her part was expanded
as the show went on because she was
really good in it but she was a
supporting character and of course that
we're gonna cast the trans actors there
because she had to appear a bit
different from everybody else and and
that worked very well and that's not me
trying to knock Laverne Cox Laverne Cox
is beautiful and very passable I feel
but you know you you could look at her
you could buy it for lack of a better
term so when trans people get cast they
pretty much always get cast in
supporting roles because the lead roles
go to sis actors there were the people
that Scarlett Johansson's
rep cited you have Jeffrey Tambor you
have Felicity Huffman you have Jared
Leto you have
God have lost his name laws and from
breakfast and Pluto on Pluto he plays
the Scarecrow madman it's got to come to
me later I'm gonna shout it out but you
know who I mean so you have these sis
actors whenever whenever it's a lead and
you know and there's more besides what I
named there Eddie Redmayne was another
one so Killian Murphy there we go so
when you have the lead roles always
going to SIS actors that's that's a
problem and there's an additional layer
to this which I actually personally
didn't even consider because even though
I made a go at acting in both Boston and
New York and never went anywhere and I
wasn't out as what you see
so my experience in trying to do that
was basically as as far as anyone was
concerned was assist presenting person
so this is where I need to give credit
reilly Silverman who is a comedian and
an actress and a very funny person she
did an article I might have been on
bustled I got to find it I'll link to it
below but what she pointed out is that
and this is gonna feed into something
that I'm about to bring up which is that
there are very few parts that are
written to explicitly be played by trans
people but here's the other part of that
because what people like to logic trap
is when you try and make the argument
that only trans people should be playing
trans parts whatever your reason for
believing that the flip argument of
those of those who want to do the larger
trap is go oh okay so that means only
six people can play sis parts
oh we gotcha here's the thing though
there are almost no parts that on a
casting sheet explicitly describe a
character as being cisgender they just
don't
they will they will explicitly describe
the characters being transgender usually
because some element of the story
requires that but very few almost never
is a character explicitly in a character
description the kind that is given to a
casting agent does it explicitly say
cisgender basically the only parts where
that would have to be the case would you
know be it's some nature of depending on
a family dynamic so if we have a
character who is who we know is the
mother as in like the biological mother
of another character okay that's gonna
have to be a cisgender a woman well I'll
backtrack doesn't have to be because
maybe one day in the future we'll get to
the point where trans person can place
this gender person and no one bats an
eye about it but we're definitely not
there at this point in time for it to be
accepted that would have to be a
cisgender woman in that role but you
need to realize for any given movie
especially when you're talking about a
TV show there are dozens there are
hundreds of parts I'm not even talking
about extras here I'm talking about
one-line characters I'm talking about
characters who are parts of groups that
again aren't just extras they are cast
to look a specific way might even be
named in the script but maybe don't have
any lines there are all sorts of parts
like that all over films all over
television and they're never specified
as cisgender so if you're gonna make the
argument that only sis people can place
his characters I would actually agree
with that but I would point out that it
is incredibly rare that a character is
ever specified to be cisgender and that
if they aren't then it's a part that
should be open to either/or which brings
up another thing that came up in the
comments a lot which was people were
making the argument to touch back on
Scarlett Johansson again they were
making the argument that it should go to
the best person for the role and they
tried to say that's why she got the part
and you can make that argument if there
is an audition process
if someone auditions
and properly in a case like this
auditions against trans actors as well
and is ultimately decided by the
filmmakers to be the best person for the
part then you can still make the
argument they are the best person for
the role now that's not going to still
fly with everybody understand that but
you can't make that argument in a case
like what happen with Scarlett Johansson
because she and Rupert Sanders the
director who had they at work before
they simply attach themselves to that
project
there was no audition for that she
wasn't up against she wasn't in
consideration against anybody else much
less a trans actor so she didn't beat
anybody out for that if you want an
example of a sis actor playing a trans
role where there was a very long very
extended audition process that would be
that would be Hilary Swank in boys don't
cry that movie almost didn't happen
because they went through audition phase
after audition phase after audition face
after audition phase and didn't think
they could find anyone who could do the
part and eventually she did it now I
can't find a confirmation that they were
actually auditioning trans men as well
as sis women for that part but knowing
how things kind of wore in the 90s when
that movie got made I could believe that
if any trans men were auditioning if
they were either in a mid transitional
phase you know didn't have facial hair
yet or were or were identifying as male
or and and weren't on hormone
adjustments or whatever yet that they
would still be marked down as being
women at the time that's me kind of
supposing I don't actually know so
coming back to the original thing that I
was saying well not original thing I'm
jumping around but where I was a second
ago so this being assists Part A
cisgender role almost never specify
especially when you're talking about
supporting cast so I would make the
argument that any role that does not
specify
I should be open to both cysts and
transgender actors and should then go to
whoever works in the park best the
problem is is that presently in the
minds of writers directors casting
agents casting directors and at this
point still I think the majority of the
movie-going audience cisgender is the
default cisgender is the norm and this
is not me arguing statistics I know
statistically it is far more common than
any you know gender variant whatever the
identification may be but what I'm the
point that I'm making about that is we
when a part is being cast anything that
is not specified tends to default to a
standard template and the standard
Hollywood template has been white
twenties cisgender if a part is not
specified as being anything other than
those it will default to that and
actually I'd add a subcategory to male
any part that is not a romantic part or
is not you know written specifically to
be female and you know functionally in
the story is a part that could work as
either a man or a woman historically has
usually been cast as a man now I kind of
like that's a little bit of an atom
because that was sort of the one that
started to get the most emphasis being
worked on I think an attention towards
the race issue is something that has
been improving and we are seeing more
diverse supporting cast these days
because people are trying to break the
pattern of well they didn't specify so
they must mean they must mean a white
person and I would like to see the same
considerations start to be given to
cisgender and again I'm not saying that
these parts should automatically be
designated transgender I'm saying that
when it doesn't specify it should be of
properly open casting but the reality of
things right now is that is not the case
it's absolutely not the stand
maybe it's in a couple sporadic cases
where people are really putting in the
effort to try and open things up more in
the casting process but that's just not
where we are
so anybody's saying you know fine trans
actors for trans roles that needs this
actors for sis roles I actually started
to go fine but I'll point out the
majority of roles don't specify either
way and those should be open to
everybody and they're jet and they're
just not but more than that I had it was
an odd thing people that I don't really
have a place to put this in terms of
where I'm forming my argument and
everything I'm talking about but I want
to address it anyway because you know
for all the trans characters who have
been played by sis actors as I said we
don't have sis characters being played
by trans actors except because I know
someone will bring it up the Bond girl
quote-unquote people love to quote the
the trivia fact that there was a
transgender Bond girl except there
wasn't not really what they're referring
to is in I believe the film him out in
81 I think it was for your eyes only
there's a scene at a pool there was a
large number of women and scantily clad
swimwear one of those women was a trans
woman now it got a little bit extra
attention because it just so happened
that as a publicity shot they took a
picture of Roger Moore who's James Bond
at the time posing with all of these
women so means that there is a shot of
the official James Bond in an official
publicity photo sharing a picture with a
trans woman now I have not been able to
confirm whether or not anyone on set
knew at the time that she was trans but
it didn't matter she wasn't a Bond girl
she was a glorified act she wasn't even
glorified she was an extra she's not a
Bond girl any more than a random
scientist fiddling a knob in gold
fingers you know sort of base gets to
claim to be a Bond villain you know when
you say Bond villain you mean the big
villains we say Bond girl you mean the
main women that he's with so no and not
too
I will point to the fact that early 80s
again I think anyone but I could be
wrong on my ear but early eighties so if
you can't find me an example that is you
know better than almost 40 years old
that kind of illustrates a problem
doesn't it and and there is a problem so
let me come back to that question should
only trans people trans actors play
trans roles yes doesn't that mean that
trans actors can't play anything other
than trans roles and doesn't that mean
that everyone else must be locked down
and you can't shift around anything ever
know so this is where people like to you
know you this is logically inconsistent
and all this here's the thing when
people break that and break these things
down to try and do these logic traps
what they the way that you accomplish
that is by stripping out all the nuance
is by stripping out all the
circumstances is by stripping out all
the specifics that make the situation
what it is so I'm gonna use a very pare
down analogy that I'm hoping will
illustrate what I'm trying to say if we
can hopefully agree as a starting
premise that trans I I would actually
say lgbtq+ in general bullets will stick
with trans here that trans actors are
not cast consistently even in the parts
written for them they are under cast
they are underrepresented so I'm hoping
that you will accept that going in
because if you're gonna argue that with
me then honestly I'd like to think if
you're gonna argue even that point with
me you probably stopped watching before
now but whatever we'll move forward so
imagine in your home in some room you
have piles of stuff doesn't matter what
it is absolutely does not matter but
you've got these pie
of stuff and some of the piles are
bigger some of the piles are smaller and
you decide and you tell people you know
what I think it'd be better if there was
the same amount of stuff in every pile
you know what I'm gonna see what I can
do about this and you then proceed to
start to take more stuff - and you're
not taking it from anywhere but you're
just adding more stuff to the piles that
have less and you're not adding anything
to the piles that are bigger and then
somebody comes in and goes whoa whoa
whoa I thought you were all about
equality well yeah I am I'm trying to
get everybody equal be nice for the
symmetry if nothing else well no no no
no see because you're giving more stuff
to the piles that have less and you're
not giving any stuff to the piles that
are bigger that's not a quality that's
treating people differently if you want
equality you should be giving the same
amount of stuff to all the piles but
that won't change anything the problem
with trying to make an argument that
says well if you want equality why are
you requesting to be treated differently
than everybody else is because we don't
currently live in an equal society and
that's not that's by no means exclusive
to LGBTQ people but we don't live in a
state of equality currently so when you
try to correct that by giving what
appears from the outside to be
favoritism to those who don't have as
much that's trying to get everybody on
an even footing or as close to it as we
can get but anyone who says well no true
equality is everybody gets the same and
nobody gets an advantage all that does
is maintain the status quo you put the
same amount you add the same amount of
stuff to every pile of stuff that gap
between the piles that anymore on the
pilot has left never moves never changes
so you can't you can't insist that we
begin behaving as if things were equal
when they aren't once things get to a
better State
quality once we get to a point as I said
when trans actors can be cast in a role
originally intended for this person or
even where they are playing a sis person
the characters cysts the actors trans
nobody says anything if and when that
ever happens fine since people can play
trans actors because we will have
reached the status of equal standing
that will be a point at which all things
are equal and then yes everybody can
cross over but we're not there yet and
behaving as if we are there when we
aren't just in beds the problems that
already exist so I think I'm going to
wrap up there so if the the to long did
not watch version is at this point in
time I feel trans parts should be played
by trans actors and no that does not
mean that everyone has to be limited to
being the only thing that they
themselves are now how do we ever get
things - that even status so we get
there I don't know I mean I don't I mean
I I'm uh I don't even know what I am I'm
a youtuber I'm a entertainment pundit if
I'm gonna be pretentious about it I'm
not a sociologist I don't know how to
fix systemic problems I don't I don't
claim to but what I do know is behaving
as if the problem doesn't exist it'll
never get fixed so it's my hope that my
RIA dressing this issue and addressing
some of the stuff that came up in the
comments from the last time I talked
about it will give some folks a better
understanding of what it was I was
talking about because I actually had
clips from that video pulled by a
youtuber about 20 times as big as I was
you know cherry-picking certain parts
and sort of using it as a as a takedown
again a certain amount of it was that
logic trap stuff that I mentioned you
know where you strip out the nuance or
in
case of mine and another youtubers video
strip out the context of everything else
that was said and you know you boil it
down to these quick sound bytes and yeah
everything falls apart
and while the youtuber himself who I'm
choosing to not name while he in the
video was a little bit dismissive he
wasn't rude his viewers his subscribers
kind of descended on my channel and I
had about a week of really ugly hateful
comments that I had to clear out and I
haven't had to deal with a volume like
that I think since I talked about
Kathleen Kennedy last and even in that I
was clearing out hateful comments
directed at her and directed at
primarily you know the creators I was
talking about very few directed at me I
had to clear out a whole lot of stuff
from commenters hatefully attacking me
and I know that they found that video
because it was cited by this other
youtuber and I don't know I'd make no
presumption that this guy watches my
stuff I suspect he did a search on some
of the more viewed videos on the topic I
say more viewed he the the youtubers
that he picked were me and somebody
who's about know a little shy at twice
my size but still significantly smaller
than he is I find it interesting that he
cherry picked from people much smaller
than him and I have no assumption and
I'm sure a fair amount of you know who
I'm talking about I have no assumption
that he will ever watch this or that he
would ever want to have a conversation
because I'm not opposed to trying
I can get angry over these things but if
someone is genuinely trying to
understand as opposed to undermine
belittle me my life and people like me
even if their starting position is one
of disagreement I will try to make them
understand better not through lectures
but through a conversation and that is
why at the end of every video I ask as
long as you can keep the comments polite
no personal attacks
whatever your thoughts are groove with
me or disagree drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
there's all the things to do you know
what they are you don't need me to tell
you I will mention that the patreon is
the big one
but everything else links in the
description including to the article
that Riley Silverman wrote I would
encourage you to check it out she was
able to infuse her own personal
experiences into that and make it a
really relatable story I think even for
people who don't have non-standard
gender identity so yeah thanks for
listening if you're still here god I
probably went on a long time with this
but until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]